>>> YOARE IN AN UBER ON YOUR
WAY TO THE AIRPORT WHEN YOU SEE
AN APARTMENT BUILDING ON FIRE
WITH PEOPLE TRAPPED INSIDE.
NATURALLY, YOU CALL 911.
YOUR UBER DRIVER TAKES A
DIFFERENT TACT.
HE PULLS OVER AND RUNS INTO THE
BUILDING.
HE IS WITH ME NOW.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE.
>> THANK YOU.
IT'S HUMBLING TO BE HERE.
>> I APPRECIATE YOU.
YOU COULD HAVE KEPT DRIVING.
WHY DID YOU PULL OVER AND RUN
TOWARDS THE FIRE?
>> I HAVE A HABIT OF DOING THAT.
>> RUNNING INTO BURNING
BUILDINGS?
>> IT'S LIKE SITUATIONS PRESENT
THEMSELVES.
YOU ARE LIKE, DO SOMETHING.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
SOMETHING COMES OVER YOU, AND
YOU FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING.
YOU DON'T THINK ANYMORE.
IT'S JUST MOTION.
>> THAT'S YOU.
YOU ARE BUILT THAT WAY.
MOST PEOPLE AREN'T.
WHEN YOU PULLED OVER AND RAN IN,
WHAT DID YOU FIND INSIDE?
>> WE PULLED OVER.
THE FIRST THING WE DID WAS -- I
WASN'T THINKING ABOUT GOING
INSIDE.
TELL THEM, COME OUT.
MADE THE PHONE CALLS.
IS ANYONE INSIDE?
PEOPLE CAME OUT.
I HEARD SOMEONE SAY, THERE'S
SOMEONE INSIDE.
IN THAT MOMENT, I RAN INSIDE.
HE WAS RESISTING.
HE WANTED TO GET SOMETHING.
HE HAD TIME CONSIDERING THE FIRE
WAS ON THE SECOND FLOOR.
WENT UPSTAIRS.
SAW THE OTHER WOMAN.
SHE WAS RESISTING.
I THINK SHE WAS IN SHOCK.
>> YOU HAD TO CONVINCE HER TO
LEAVE?
>> YEAH.
A LITTLE NEGOTIATING.
I TOLD HER, IF YOU ARE NOT
GOING, I'M NOT GOING.
I TOLD HER, IT'S AC THAT CAUSED
THE FIRE.
YOU ARE SAFE.
LET'S NOT GET HURT.
LET'S FOCUS ON SAFETY.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE.
>> YOU GOT HER OUT?
>> GOT HER OUT.
WENT BACK TO GET THE OTHER GUY
DOWNSTAIRS.
>> YOU GOT THE WOMAN OUT AND YOU
GOT THE GUY OUT.
THEN YOU RETURNED TO YOUR UBER
PASSENGER.
WHAT DID YOU SAY TO HER?
>> I APOLOGIZED.
SHE WAS AWESOME.
SHE'S GOING TO DO GREAT.
ASPIRING AUTHOR.
I TOLD HER -- I SAID, SORRY.
LET'S GET GOING.
SHE WAS LIKE, ARE YOU KIDDING
ME?
YOU SAVED LIVES.
>> DID YOU GET HER TO THE
AIRPORT ON TIME?
>> WE GOT THERE ON TIME.
>> THAT'S AMAZING.
I HAVE SOMETHING I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO SEE ON CAMERA THREE.
LOOK OVER HERE.
THERE SHE IS.
SHE'S PARACHUTING IN.
THIS IS YOUR UBER PASSENGER.
HAPPY TO REUNITE YOU WITH
FRITSCH.
TELL US ABOUT THE MOMENT WHERE
HE PULLED OVER.
>> IT'S SO GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> SAME HERE.
>> HOW YOU BEEN?
>> HONESTLY, YOU WERE A HERO.
YOU REACTED SO QUICKLY.
I WAS SO IMPRESSED BY HOW YOU
DIDN'T EVEN HESITATE.
JUST RAN RIGHT IN.
EVER SINCE THEN, I'VE BEEN
GETTING MESSAGES ON WHAT A HERO
YOU ARE AND HOW YOU GIVE PEOPLE
HOPE.
THESE ARE DIFFICULT TIMES.
HE REMINDED EVERYONE THAT YOU
PEELED THROUGH THE NOISE AND
REMINDED EVERYONE THERE ARE GOOD
PEOPLE OUT THERE.
I HOPE THE KIDS KNOW THEIR DAD
IS A HERO.
>> THAT'S SO NICE.
THE CEO OF UBER SAID YOU ARE A
HERO.
YOUR DAUGHTERS, WHAT DID THEY
SAY?
>> ONE CALLS ME SUPER CAT.
THE OTHER ONE -- WE HAVE
KITTENS.
SHE HAD TO COMBINE THE TWO.
SHE'S PROUD.
I'M KIND OF -- I'M CHERISHING
THE MOMENT.
I SEE THEY ARE JOYFUL.
I APPRECIATE IT.
I WANT TO SAY TO PEOPLE WHO WERE
TEMPORARILY DISPLACED, HANG IN
THERE.
I'M GLAD YOU ARE OKAY.
GOD BLESS YOU.
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE OKAY.
>> THAT IS BEAUTIFUL.
YOU DO RESTORE EVERYONE'S FAITH
IN HUMANITY.
THANKS F